"THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> WOW.
KAMALA HARRIS KICKED PENCE’S
BUTT.
JUST READING WHAT THE MEDIA
ALREADY WROTE ABOUT TONIGHT.
WHAT SHOULD YOU EXPECT?
TWO DIFFERENT VISIONS.
ONE POSITIVE AND ONE
APOCALYPTIC.
PENCE COULD POINT TO AN ECONOMY
BOUNCING BACK FROM A NOSE DIVE
NECESSARY TO FLATTEN THE CURVE
AND SAVE LIVES.
CURRENT UNEMPLOYMENT MATCHES
2012 OBAMA.
THE DEMs WILL SAY THAT NUMBER IS
TRUMP’S FAULT.
IMAGINE IF THERE WAS NO IT
SHUTDOWN.
SHE WILL BRING UP THE 200,000
DEAD.
THAT WAS FORECASTED IF WE DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT AND TWO MILLION
DEAD IF WE ONLY CHASED
IMPEACHMENT.
HARRIS WILL TRY TO SOCIALIST
DISTANCE HERSELF.
GOOD LUCK.
CO-SPONSORED BERNIE SANDERS
MEDICARE FOR ALL BILL AND BACKED
THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
AND LET’S NOT FORGET KAMALA
HARRIS PUSHED BAIL FOR
CRIMINALS.
WHEN WE NEEDED LAW AND ORDER,
SHE CHOSE THUGS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WHO WILL BE
THE VICE-PRESIDENT BUT WHO WILL
BE P.
>> A HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
TOGETHER WITH JOE BIDEN AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THERE YOU GO.
MANY SUPPORT BIDEN DESPITE HIS
FLAWS BECAUSE IT’S IMPLIED SHE
IS REALLY IN CHARGE WANT PENCE’S
GOAL IS TO LET AMERICA KNOW WHO
YOU ARE GETTING IF JOE WINS.
THE MOST LIBERAL SENATOR THERE
IS.
SHE IS REALLY NUMBER 1 WITH